this huge marquee match up as we got
wesley in studio maybe to help us call
this game wesley
yeah put him to work
i mean do you keep an eye on your
rivals during the game or do you just
focus on your own game you were aware
that lanier was
was doing well yeah no i knew they were
both in trouble yesterday but i mean i
don't really pay much attention i just
focus on my game
i i think
pretty much
the top players uh fabiano myself and
lanier i think we had the long season so
we're very tired at this point we just
played a lot of tournaments also
traveling i think uh we're not in our
best form as you can see yesterday
we all played some bad games uh
today i thought fabiano played
his first 25 moves very quickly so i
thought he would equalize comfortably in
the opening but
now i i see the opposite colored bishops
but uh
it's still very difficult for white to
win but
even with this past pawn wesley
yeah i think so because it can't really
push it
so probably it's
60 percent chance for white to win 60
percent chance okay yes we're talking
about that somehow it feels like this
quincy photo is not the right direction
anything it's going to focus on that
point okay but black preterite yeah
but okay but you can stick your pawn on
e7 you can put your rope maybe on a good
day on the d8 square as well you can go
rook c8 and rook on the e7 don't you
think i want to put my pawn on e7 i want
to keep the seventh rank open
just so that i can
massage you a little bit when you put
your pawn on e7 you're one sport closer
to promotion
that's a good thing this is a good thing
that's what they say
remind the e7 king g8 also okay okay
wesley all right yeah hello hello we're
gonna come back we're gonna keep our
careful eye on this because
obviously bobby's down to very little
time uh we we do want to get to wesley's
game wisely
they're in time pressure so we we can't
imagine now rookie is on the board as we
see here there's only 126
left for fabius this is a very
consequential move offering a trade
there's a threat of queen f8 check by
the way leading to mate
bobby better not overlook that one
a real threat on the board so 86 no but
the h6 you take taken queen and 8.
so kg8 might be the only move
but then take that quincy
right then about to play queen g6
yeah this looks like it's very very
tricky like uh
with 52 seconds on the clock i think i
think you know cherry life already hk or
h5 on your mobile
but 8686 you're not aware about the
sacrifice on h6 and and bishop takes h6
yeah that's a good move yeah maybe a6 is
played a6 is on the board on the board
chicks
can't chevron maybe
number wait maybe it's uh maybe he's
leading to a pro is there a propeller
there
there's not purple
after you take on e after you sacrifice
your bishop and take him on e8
no because he has got queen e7 check
queen f8 queen is seven
after king h7 effect oh play the check
first oh yeah yeah
that's a great point help me with your
with your thoughts so i can share them
with the audience bishop takes h66 right
now then i think black has to play king
h7 after bishop h6 sir let's try bishop
86 make this point let's see let's see
if we can get it on screen so we can
follow this analysis
bishop h6 looks winning at first sight
but then khmer i think
so just back up back up one move
yesterday to show the point bishop takes
eight six if you take now bishop takes a
six immediately you need to see the what
we were analyzing just quickly we just
take they take
and then queen fa check
and wesley's point is after you play
king 87 first drop queen e7 check and
you get a check on the next move so
black doesn't get to play queen the one
checking queens exactly and try to fight
back with per pet so that was the key
all right we could go back to the live
board now yeah that was the intermezzo
so bishop h6 is uh possible but after
bishop h6
h7 wesley that was your suggestion
yes and the point is that if they take
queen e7 i have king h6
right i don't know king a bishop a6 it
looks very close to winning for white it
sure does yeah it really really really
does really right there but it does that
pawn on h3 wishes were on h4 i think
because yeah after bishop h6
yeah king h7 looks like the only move
right i don't see anything else right
but then can't we just withdraw our
bishop by four doesn't do the job
wow well i'm also not convinced that
that position even at the end the one
that we looked at
when you give me a check on e7 i go all
the way to f5 king g6 queen takes a king
f5 man that looks lost queen d7 yeah two
points
yeah yeah
this is linear though ticking down
thanks wesley for your patience
lanier is ticking down himself big
result for you of course because a
victory here ties you for first
yeah it's a very long tournament living
around he's taken away e8 takes each i
assume he's going to take on eight six
right or a queen queen if they check and
he's thinking
there's going to be no perpetual check
queen of a checking h7 queen takes e8 we
need three queen takes e3 and then
he'll do something like no i was going
to say queen d7 and then try to walk
with the king about queen b5 i put the
queen on b8 and i just run my b pawn
whoa how do you ever defend the
apologies
yeah check no but queen b5 there's
quincy one maybe queen takes e3 queen
takes b5
c1 and then i get king g1 queen king h2
and do i do i get to run for the hills
is the question there's a lot of running
but what was wrong with
or maybe the king escaped for some
reason no queen before check though king
f2 f1 and king queen down king f
and then queen d4 again king e2 no more
checks
when is no cheque
that was not our no that is the idea
that's the main idea he could have taken
on a6 first or do rook takes ea first
that was our main idea no king hm we
just bishop teenaged
but so what actually i was thinking
about bishop g6
we have g7 king g7 queen e7 king and
chicks queen m6
i have four fun now
you're not mean person
that's a lot he did play king h7 that's
on the board that's on the board he
could take on g7 as you said and just
take a ton of guys that's for fun yeah
that's huge
you can see the light board right now
yeah i think i should see the live board
right now
yeah will he take on g7 he's now the one
down to near a minute as his clock ticks
down
what move number are we on 39 39 so one
more move before we can breathe two more
moves two more moves two more moves move
40 the fame infamous move 40. the last
move of time control and also just
recreate this bishop
yes as well i mean not as easy to break
through but if he can get the bishop if
he can get rid of the light square
bishop somehow
or get all that material as you
mentioned what will he do he's got 36
seconds
ticking down yeah even bishop ether
looks very strong i think he's taking on
g7 is queen have aydah move
queen of fate king a chick ah queen of
no pardon me uh bishop g68 king jesus
let's see if he takes on 16 seconds he's
retreating yeah i retreat the other
practical decision brought the bishop
back and so what should yeah black is
two points down it's like
stupid it's not a lot of fun
queen bit
yeah also white can play just e7
and then just cement the bishop one day
on the c5 square so what about queen b3
yeah e7 i take that pawn
yeah queen f5
queen d3 e7 h8
yeah white has queen c8
queen queen
juice king h8 queen v1 checked on the
board and only one more move to time
control well if you're going to win the
b2 pawn
has to be winning right
ah
yeah
uh is that the winning
is that the win at the bishop i don't
know i have no idea yeah no i wouldn't
play bishop c1 bishop c1 yeah i don't
play bishop c1 you don't take that
chance
yeah that there is that you know i hate
the idea that i could throw away the the
the victory by going into what is
manifestly a winning and he's going to
realize it's not he's playing is it
actually
there's black up chances to drop the
queens are traded there we have the 40th
move and one more move for fabi we can
get off of this game now as surely we'll
just make his 40th move and it's going
to be a long time before they get to
their finish looks like ray robson
only drew
ray was in the driver so that puts ray
at one and a half along with wesley
wesley uh let's talk about your game
let's pull your game up now oh god yeah
and your thoughts about the opening he
played he played queen g4 it seemed to
freeze you for a moment when this
happened it after i did if you know i i
did the chessable course
on one e4 so i covered this but
i don't know i forgot whether i should
castle first or play d4 right away
because there are these lines with queen
g4 like i could castle first and
then play d4 and then avoid this line
this is fine but i thought
because i thought like in step 966 i
thought g6 was more accurate that way
later after like d4 takes x bishop g7
black off some castle rook c8 ideas but
that's the main line
so that's why i thought he would play
like castle castle and lack of a quick
rook c8
so this is the main line and it's well
known to be fine for black but they play
knight is first which surprised me well
first of all i wasn't
expecting the sicilian with d6 like i
haven't seen him played it recently for
queen g4
and i'm i'm sure he prepared this
but i can't remember if i in my course
or whether i i was
and i think castle first but are you
saying that you're going to have to go
look at your own course
yeah i can offer you a discount on your
course
yeah i did it a few months ago it always
needs to be
checked f3 so this end game is just
equal but at least i avoid this
preparation b35
yeah i think g4 is good
because if you manage to play h5 then
black is fine like if i play king e2 you
can play h5
and then g6
again then g6
and then knight d7 f5
black completely
but after g4 also the position is equal
but that's the thing when modern players
prepare with modern computers hard to
get advantage especially they catch you
so
yeah i thought
i think his critical mistake here is uh
if okay maybe a6 i think f5 is a mistake
i think maybe b5 or knight c5 was more
solid
but maybe white is slightly better there
well i always had the impression that
this defensive knight on d3 is so good
that i'm anxious as black to get rid of
it to trade it so i would have thought
knight c5 yeah knife if i make sense he
played f5 and this is where things
definitely
went in your favor yeah i think he
forgot after i think he was intending
rook g three after object rock g8 he
just missed rook h3 i'm pretty sure
that's what he missed
oops or g2 knight
f2 so
i think this was a semi blunder
and why why is this so bad
oh you mean this rook gets trapped yeah
oh
that's nasty
okay i get you i understand you and so
yeah age for black if lafayette i think
and here
i mean it's one-way traffic now yeah
everything is just really really good
for you everything that could go wrong
for black went wrong it is it has
happened yeah so smooth
a very smooth win yeah i mean an equal
end game and then just he made some
blunders
and
yeah as i said i think uh the three top
season sermon on the best form we played
played a lot i played the online
tournament just before coming here yes
we were aware of uh
quite a by the way you you you performed
magnificently online and offline right
no no seriously i
i have i've
i've uh predicted that you would be the
winner but now you're
you're here at st louis and yeah welcome
to st louis i feel like
and
uh 2021 u.s championships you feel
really at home don't you
yeah i mean
this tournament is going to be very
tough because there are a lot of
ambitious young players also some lower
rated but very strong players the
juniors are here junior champions uh sam
shankland so everyone's very ambitious
in this tournament so but this is my
uh fifth or sixth i think this is my
sixth u.s championship wow so i'm used
to the tough grind
right yeah right two free days uh very
useful for you to get uh yourself into
shape wesley if you keep up uh your form
of today
you're gonna be
right up there as a contender thank you
i just wanna play some good chess i
think yesterday the game didn't
i made some mistakes so i just
i don't even care about their soul just
wanna
play well for the fans also to for
myself are you serious you don't want to
win a third champion
well it'll be nice but it's
way too early just wanna play good
because if you make like
10 blunders and win the tournament then
it's not fun either
i'll take it
uh blundering my way to victory isn't uh
isn't the way i would like it to happen
but yeah
sometimes sometimes uh you're not
delayed lucky win could be all it takes
and yesterday you saved a difficult game
so yeah
yeah okay wesley thank you and thank you
for your comments uh for bobby as well
uh
much appreciated it thank you anytime
you want to be a commentator you know
come on down